Hey, guys, we are so happy
that you came back
for another episode
of the Wine Down.
Today, we are joined
by Jean Elie,
who plays Issa's brother,
Ahmal.
To talk about
"Lowkey Movin' On."
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
You know, you and Molly
have just had sort of, like--
You know like in season one,
you guys
have argumentative fights,
but this fight gets--
You guys physically step
to each other.
So, do you think Issa
and Molly can, sort of,
come back from this?
Well, I would say
guys are a unique breed.
Yeah, we're completely
different.
It's like y'all fight
and you become best friends.
Right.
Once women fight, it's a wrap.
-It was a public violation too.
-Yeah.
There's an embarrassment
element to it.
It was at Issa's event.
So...
I don't know how you could
come back from that
without having a fully-candid
conversation.
Like I-- For me,
I could never look
-at my friend the same way.
-It's like--
It's like, uh, a mirror broke,
and then now you put it
back together, and you can still
see cracks in it.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, wait, how do you come back
from that?
-(SIGHS)
-How do you come back
from a cracky-ass mirror?
-Just be looking at--
-Just remember--
Just look at your little--
little section, right here,
and you good.
You get used
to that reflection
after a while?
Like... (WINCES) I get it.
(CHUCKLES)
One of my favorite moments
this episode
is Kelli pretending
to be British.
And you jumping
to call her out on it.
-(CHUCKLES)
-Can you talk about,
just in you filming that scene,
and the Ahmal and Kelli dynamic
-is... great.
-JEAN ELIE: I think Kelli
is brilliantly basic.
She's so brilliant, she's basic.
And the fact that she thought
she was gonna pass off
South Central London.
Like... (CHUCKLES)
Come on, are you serious?
(CHUCKLES)
So-- And I just loved
how Ahmal just literally
pokes holes in her story
the whole time.
And she's literally trying
to cover up...
every time. (CHUCKLES)
So one of the things
I think we can pose
is I wanted to talk about
Issa's impostor syndrome
at the beginning of the episode.
And then, finally,
giving herself credit
for pulling it off
-at the block party.
-Yeah.
That's real.
I mean we've all had projects,
we've all, you know,
put ourselves out there.
And there's no worse feeling
than feeling like...
"Why did I think that
I could actually pull this off?"
-Yeah.
-Like--
And-- But she did it.
Like, no one can take that
-from her.
-Yeah, she sure did.
PRENTICE PENNY: You know
that energy is good, right?
That energy of like...
"I don't want to be seen
as an impostor--" And obviously,
Issa, the character,
has had a lot of big ideas.
And not always
the best follow-through.
And I think this is like,
"Oh, I've got investors,
and people putting their money
in on this thing.
And this is like, I think,
for my professional career
as well..."
This ain't like something
that's just like,
"Oh, it's just gonna get seen
by my girlfriends."
This is like, "Oh, I did this
for the neighborhood."
And there is a--
And I think,
even in the back of her mind,
like her best friend
didn't want to ask her boyfriend
because she didn't necessarily
fully believe
that this wasn't one of those
schemes, you know?
That it wasn't going
to be executed properly.
That it could actually
pan out.
Exactly, so there's an element
of, like, proving herself.
And that pressure is
the fucking worst.
How have y'all dealt
with impostor syndrome?
When you know you're capable?
Ooh, I'm still
working through that right now.
Like, I literally Googled
impostor syndrome,
like, "Oh, I deal with this shit
all the time."
And I'm like--
I'm trying to work through it.
Really just calling myself
on my shit, you know?
Um... journal.
And then, um,
the people around me
literally help.
Yeah.
For me, the fear is...
Not necessarily that I'm going
to be found out,
as when I'm projecting something
I'm not...
But that who I am isn't enough.
And that--
-That is--
-That's exactly what it is.
I remember one time
I was on a show,
and one of the best things
I thought the showrunner
ever did was say,
"I don't know."
And it was so freeing,
that I just was like,
"Oh, that's a very easy--"
Like, nobody thinks of you
any less.
I think that's the fear,
is that we won't be enough.
I'ma use that.
But I don't know.
ISSA RAE: Yeah.
Well, as always,
thank you for Wining Down
with us.
And be sure to come back
next week after we break down
episode six.
-Um, see you guys then.
-(CHEERING)
-Cheers.
Halfway through,
halfway through.
Yeah, halfway through.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪